ESPN NFL draft analyst and college
football analyst Todd McShea how have
you been
Todd really good how you doing I'm doing
great
I know you're on the move and I
appreciate you calling and right here
where you headed
where you headed to right now headed to
Athens Georgia okay I need a trip next
time you can have one plate and make a
quick drive over that's good okay so I
guess before we get to the meat of what
I want to talk about you're heading to
Athens Georgia what did you make of the
college football playoff first top four
and the rest of it Todd what do you
think there brother I thought it was
pretty fair you know I mean I probably
would have put LSU over Ohio State but
who cares at this point we got enough
time I think you just had to go through
probably a softer run I'm in cover
schedule and Ohio State has been
dominant every game but probably to my
viewing has not played the same level of
competition but I think they got the
right four in there and then kind of
stacked it properly after that no no
major issues okay because obviously you
know these teams are gonna play each
other in short order Ohio State and Penn
State Saturday before Thanksgiving and
then LSU and Alabama coming up in a
couple of days is this like the Super
Bowl for prospecting in the NFL LSU
Alabama it's the first tape I'm gonna
watch right like when the season is over
and I sit down and say alright how am I
gonna get started on evaluating up to
400 prospects that's a pretty good game
to start on I've got 24 players right
now that have draftable grades and there
may be more by the time we get there you
know some underclassmen maybe are flying
a radar so 24 in a single game is is
rare you know any time you get over
about 1213 that range you're talking
about one of the better prospect games
in the country and this is going to be
special well looking at what you put up
on the ESPN family of Internet's the day
before Halloween you've got
no fewer than five players in your top
15 playing in this game walk me through
who is the top prospects that you're
seeing on Saturday in this game I mean
obviously the quarterbacks - etana Vella
is is the most interesting I think in
the game because of the health issues
and then going up against this defense
so how is he gonna perform how how
healthy is he and then on the perimeter
what are the matchups going to be and
you know Jerry duty who I think is one
of the best five players in the country
and should be the first wide receiver
I'll support how's that once you going
to try to defend him and knowing that
it's not just Judy but it's Henry rug
who's gonna run a four to nine or
something like that
at the combine when you're announcing it
and and going down the list and Devante
Smith another wide receiver who I've got
a third-round grade on and he's the
third best receiver for this team so how
do you match up against these guys what
do you do defensively if you're LSU and
four - specifically how how ready is he
to go and can he hold up for four
quarters I mean Ellis is obviously gonna
try to get after him and then on the
flip side you got you've got your
borough who's probably the most
interesting story of the year in college
football I can honestly say this I've
seen you know we've seen whence come out
of kind of small school and not know
much about him I can never remember a
player playing at a big-time NFL
pipeline school one year to the next
going from what I thought was maybe a
seventh rounder a draftable free agent
bring him into camp - legitimately might
be a first-round pick and that's what
Joe borough has done so to me the
storylines are just as as fun as the you
know anticipation of the prospects in
this game Todd McShea here on the Rich
Eisen show let's dig in on the
quarterbacks is this is this a
possibility certainly when we're all at
the combine next March late February
early March that we are talking about
this game and what it means to be the
first overall drafted quarterback
Guinness Draught it will this game have
something to do with that do you think I
think it could yeah I think it could and
I had to think about it for a second but
I it absolutely could
you never evaluate any player especially
a quarterback off of one game but you
only get a handful of games throughout a
quarterbacks career typically where you
can go and it's close to apples to
apples in terms of what you're going to
see in the NFL and these are the type
types of games obviously the national
championship semi-finals SEC
championship game but regular-season
game this is as close as you can have to
that comparison that when you look to
what he's going to be in the NFL so I
think absolutely I think you've got a
race between two ax and and Joe and then
Justin Herbert from Oregon I'm just
playing really well Jacob Eason who was
was at Georgia with Jake from and froms
another guy both of those guys I think
will likely be in need in the the
upcoming NFL Draft and from is not as
talented as Eason but has had a better
career and sent decent packing back to
the to Washington to your play so and
then Jordan loved a lot of guys I talked
to who people don't really know about
coming out of Utah State but a lot of
scouts in the league really like this
guy's upside so right there that six
quarterbacks with I'm not saying they're
all gonna be first rounders but in some
people's minds in the league they have a
first-round grade on them so that makes
it interesting then we we haven't gotten
into like Jalen Hertz and Nate Stanley
and those other quarterbacks but six
quarterbacks having a chance to be in
the first round is that's pretty good
and then you know to his durability is
that gonna be the issue because again
the Dolphins we you know we've all been
saying and we I'm including myself that
dolphins have flat out tank for to they
they had to a had the dolphins from what
I've heard and what I've been told that
to had the Dolphins at hello when he
looked off the Georgia safety and beat
Georgia in the Nash
ship game that that was another that he
had them in the grade all the time all
time throws okay right so uh so what
what is currently going into this game
looking over the steering wheel the the
to evaluation Todd mature he's one of
the best deep passers I've ever
evaluated to uh is one of the more
accurate overall passers I've ever
evaluated
he has exceptional anticipation and
timing he's really naturally instinctive
he just he kind of feels things that
most other young quarterbacks don't I
think he can read things faster I which
is hard I know that sounds
counterintuitive he just he senses
things and feels if I think in terms of
pure progressions like okay the safety
is rolling over now I need to go to my
second progression I think he can
improve in that area and a lot of guys
do from their second to third or fourth
year of playing at big-time level
staying healthy we worry about that with
everyone but I size is no longer that
big of a deal in the NFL it really isn't
and you can say yeah well this guy
hasn't been healthy but you know Tyler's
coming on and you know the list of
quarterbacks that are under six to that
are having success is long enough that
you just don't worry a lot of guy like
to uh with that it's just more about the
durability and Kenny hang in there and
then can he perform when he's ganged up
that's the other part now I think that's
one area that I would have concern with
right now just based off of watching him
and the last two games I've had him why
he's gotten injured so that's probably
the number one thing but he from a icing
standpoint he's special he's not like
very other any guys that I've ever
really watched he just has a feel for it
and touch and knows how to layer the
ball in and and knows the anticipation
aspect of it and where guys should be
versus where they are and it's uh it's
fun to watch he's he's a really special
player years and then the fact that he's
coming off of that ankle surgery playing
in this
against LSU whole country watch in two
versus three in terms of the college
football playoff rankings it just adds
not just to the SEC drama but to the
drama that we're all talking about for
the draft todd McShea here on the Rich
Eisen show then we look at your top
prospects and III can't blame you in a
way I mean chase young he's so stupidly
good he's so amazingly good as I've
mentioned before and I'll stay here to
you Todd I don't need the play-by-play
group and analysts to identify him
pre-snap with a with a circle or an
arrow like I can see I can see him you
know like he's that good he jumps off a
screen like that do you think there are
teams out there that would take him over
a quarterback even if they need one what
do you think that good he's that good
where you would eat at least consider it
yeah he's that good I mean he's you know
when you why he's like he's like
Jadeveon you know like mile Garrett
those guys weren't just when you're
watching the tape he you it's so obvious
how good he is and I love the Bosa
Brothers I did and I actually stood on
the table and well the 40 times not good
and the shuttles and all this I was all
in on on Nicky and Joey Bosa but this
guy's different you know he's got a lot
of the mechanics that made that make the
BOCES special but he's got a lead
athleticism and quickness so to answer
your question if it comes down to a two
of verses chase young and the team is
desperate for a quarterback you know the
answer there go quarterback right but
he's so good that he actually makes you
I think he would split a room or at
least have a few guys in the room saying
you know what are you sure should we
should we make this decision and that's
that says a lot because if it's anything
other than a quarterback and it speaks
to the level of talent now I mean we
have so many months to go
which makes this but this is fun this is
fun so let me go down this wormhole a
little bit more with you Todd McShea
so let's say the Jets get first overall
pick because they sure can I mean
there's a way of two ways we're sitting
here right now
you know Cincinnati would have him but
let's go jets your Joe Douglas all right
and you've got the first overall pick
you can add chase young right here right
now and say I've got darn old I got my
guy or do you trade that first overall
pick for otoño picks because you know
somebody is so desperate for either
young because they have their
quarterback or they're desperate for
tool like say the team in the AFC East
and you could hold the Dolphins up from
maybe every damn draft pick that they
have amassed in order to try and get to
a what do you do if you're Joe Douglas
based on what you're seeing from the
Jets right now first of all you're a
jerk because you know I'm good friends
with I'm sorry but you know I mean
honestly I I such a cop-out answer I'm
not doing it because it's Jeff Joe knows
I say what I say it would have to be a
damn good offer
I mean it would have to be multiple
multiple players to walk away from a guy
like chase because because now if you
have a quarterback and I and I still
believe in Sam I think he's going to be
a really good quarterback if you can
continue to surround people around them
but if you have a quarterback and then
will potentially one of the best passers
in the league in a couple years now you
got something so two most important
positions now you get you know I don't
know move down you get a tenth of the
10th overall pick another first-round
pick and a second or a third down the
line yeah I consider it I listen I'm
gonna pick up the phone if they want to
talk about lazy on they'll pick up the
phone if they want to talk about Jamal
Adams every single GM and the NFL would
doesn't mean you're trying to make the
deal and that is definitely me speaking
for Joe and that's my guy right but you
got to listen to everything but at the
end of the day it would have to be a
sickness
I can offer to pass on on a chaise young
because I think you've got a chance to
do really really special so then let's
get off Joe Douglas in the Jets and say
you're the Bengals and and and Ryan
Finley does not win a game and they go
the hard o and 16 and they earn that
first overall pick and they could
however get to or chase young let you
through a few didn't even stutter you
didn't even say thank you he's that
special I mean New York the Jets have
Sam so yeah I know that you went in this
league is what the quarterback you know
that better than anyone so I think as
much as you want to chase young and his
special as he is and your grade might be
a touch higher on him than then to or
any of the other quarterbacks if you got
a chance to get one of the top 10
quarterbacks in the league and that's
what I think too it can be eventually I
think that's the route yeah always have
to go you know man I gotta tell you Todd
I appreciate you saying Sam's still the
guy in the in New York and I sure hope
he is but I mean to to say he's
regressing is an insult to the word
regressing I mean that that chest pass
that he flipped towards the Dolphins
defense this past week the the the
staring at the ball but just got snapped
past him as it sat in the end zone and
he didn't move is just you know was
stunning to me that that's not the kid
that they drafted that's not the Const
from a pick six is his first
professional throw
so that's trouble as far as I think
seeing that I'm an I place it in their
hands as an evaluator and you know what
it's real like that he you can be the
most talented quarterback in the world
and you can have all the tools and you
can be mentally tough but if you are in
a brutal situation think about anything
any career you know anything you're
doing if you're surrounded by negativity
people constantly questioning how you're
performing and a supporting cast that's
just not up to par and doesn't give you
a chance to win every day you go to work
it's hard to overcome that and so I you
know
it's gonna it will take result and what
we're gonna find out we're gonna find
out in the next year or so if Sam's got
that I i thought from day one and I
still think he does I really have always
believed in this young man because I
think he can handle it but what he's up
against is a storm that very few people
in the world are capable of of fighting
through so we're gonna find out Todd
always love our chats man have a great
safe trip down Athens and we'll chat
we'll chat with you next couple weeks I
enjoyed it
take care of buddy all right you got it
Todd make sure at McShea 13 on both
Twitter and Instagram for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV for free on VR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app